I don't know if how much you saw about
this recent Twitter dust up I was
involved in that peaked with Donald
Trump Jr tweeting about me and then that
then declining from there let's talk
through it I didn't see it okay I have
to understand like uh the way you study
Shakespeare I have to study your Twitter
I have to understand so much how much of
his sarcasm it's mostly sarcasm I mean
here's the thing and I know that there
are people who will say David you're
dealing with such serious issues it's
really not okay not to take everything
you do completely seriously but my view
is it's so incredible that I've between
chance and timing and so different
things falling into a position where
this is what I do professionally and
it's a career and it's financially
sustainable and all these different
things I don't want to end up taking
myself too seriously because I recognize
the timing and luck and all of these
other things and this could have gone a
completely different way so my approach
to a lot of this is let's not take
ourselves too seriously and in
particular on Twitter a platform that
you know the degree to which it should
be taken very seriously maybe has
changed over time I'm always sort of
thinking a little bit tongue-in-cheek on
Twitter so what happened with uh Donald
Trump Jr so or the full Arc of it yeah
to make give you a one minute Arc and
then we can pick whichever parts we want
after
a mass shooting now you might say
there's like two or three a day you're
correct after the Nashville mass
shooting at a Christian School
I tweeted
snarkily tongue-in-cheek to point that
thoughts and prayers not only aren't
particularly useful after a shooting
they also don't prevent shootings that
there's some confusion about how there
would be a shooting at a Christian
School given that it is a place where
prayer is taking place I think I I you
know jokingly said something like were
they not praying enough for correctly in
my deep journalistic Integrity you have
it I have your beautifully this is this
is the only display of journalistic to
agree I will show today okay and I have
a couple of responses beautiful and you
deleted the Tweet since then which I
regret
oh interesting we can talk about that I
would love to because it's such a yeah
interesting decision
uh because when you tweet something one
of the things I've also learned is you
don't often understand
how it's going to be read it's going to
be analyzed like I mentioned Shakespeare
like there's certain the use of certain
words that you regret saying in a
certain kind of way maybe just because
it wasn't as eloquent as as powerful it
didn't actually convey the thing um or
is a distraction to the main message all
that kind of stuff okay the actual tweet
is very surprising that there will be a
mass shooting at a Christian School
given that lack of prayer is often
blamed for these horrible events is it
possible they weren't praying enough or
correctly despite being a Christian
School
and um
a lot of people quote retweeted that
which I'm assuming was uh
the criticism so Colin Wright wrote I
used to consider you a reasonable
Progressive but you clearly devolved
into partisan hackery I'm an atheist it
cannot begin to Fathom using the murder
of children and adults at a Christian
School is an opportunity to dunk on the
concept of prayer and you responded I'm
dunking on the people who send thoughts
and prayers and do nothing else and the
shootings continue okay I'm sure there's
a lot of other interactions there's a
few other hundred thousand interactions
so do you want the ark leading to this
yes so so this is going to display do
you know what time of day I tweeted the
original one I feel like it was in the
afternoon or evening of on a Monday
3 42 pm on 27th March 27th which was a
Monday okay so basically I tweet that
and then I finished the day and I tweet
and then you go on with your day I might
have looked once at Twitter and it had 2
000 likes and a few people saying ah
this might have missed the mark but it's
sort of like it's one of my 20 000
tweets I don't know I wake up the next
morning my baby daughter did not sleep
till 7 30 the way I would like so she's
up at 6am and I get up and I'm just
there starting to make breakfast and I
glance at my phone and I'm starting to
this was when verified meant a different
thing than it means now I'm seeing all
these verified accounts that are you
know quote tweeting it and demanding a
retraction and whatever and I go oh okay
this looks like it's getting looks like
it's getting some attention
um I then continue about my day around
noon I hear from my dad that he got a
hundred messages from you should have
aborted your son to we're gonna find all
of you to whatever else my dad has no
idea what's going on he's like I don't
know what this is but I have a hundred
DMs
to everything else you can imagine
um and
I start to get emails about you know we
you know your Jewish faith this and that
and the other thing and so at that point
to me I thought this is just going to
get worse and worse and worse and so I
deleted the tweet and I really regret
doing that because over the 48 hours
that followed yes the attacks escalated
it went through Candace Owens and then
at foxnews.com Newsmax kind of peaking
with with Donald Trump Jr and it was
horrible I mean
thousands and thousands of the okay but
once I told my audience about what
happened I got thousands of messages
from people saying David only someone
who doesn't know you and is determined
to interpret this in the worst possible
Faith would think you're blaming kids
who died for getting shot of course you
weren't doing that I wish you hadn't
deleted it so that it would still be up
and you would now see the tide kind of
turning on it this was not a fun three
days regardless but I do regret having
deleted it because
um it was a pan I wanted to do the
quickest thing I thought I could to get
people to stop trying to find family
members and send them threats and so
around noon that's what I did and the
truth is the threats didn't stop anyway
because everybody had screenshotted it
and I do wish I'd left it up
and is there some degree
maybe stepping outside yourself do you
regret tweeting that in that it feeds
the mockery engine
that that fuels Twitter so like does
that tweet really represent what you
believe
it absolutely represents the disgust
with a politics that includes saying we
can't touch guns we just we can't but
we're willing to point to mental health
or say we need more prayer in schools or
whatever one thousand percent it
represents that view
is it the type of snark and sarcasm that
I would use if given an hour to discuss
the topic rather than whatever the
number of characters is now on Twitter
no definitely not and so I am very
cognizant of the fact that it was
unnecessarily provocative How It Was
Written